und ich begrüße jetzt ganz herzlich
andreas jung stellvertretender cdu csu
fraktionsvorsitzender im bundestag und
direkt gewählter abgeordneter im
wahlkreis konstanz als in baden
württemberg der junge mit welchem gefühl
haben sie denn gestern abend die unions
fraktionssitzung verlassen und um welche
erkenntnis sind sie heute ist gleich
reicher
es gab es gestern abend keine neuen
erkenntnisse wir hatten gestern eine
offene aussprache mit klaren ergebnissen
die fraktionen stärkt armin laschet den
rücken für mögliche gespräche die jetzt
stattfinden können wir haben ralph
brinkhaus mit einem klaren votum
ausgestatteten haben sehr offen über das
wahlergebnis und die konsequenzen daraus
gesprochen dieses klare votum für ralph
brinkhaus was sie gerade erwähnen dem
ging ja eine diskussion voran und dann
kam am ende ein kompromiss dabei heraus
ralph brinkhaus wurde jetzt nur für
sieben monate wiedergewählt glücklich
wäre ein jahr gewesen dem soll dieser
kompromiss denn wirklich etwas bringen
der union oder eigentlich nur armin
laschet
ich glaube die frage die kann man so
nicht stellen sondern die frage war doch
eine andere nämlich wie stellen wir uns
jetzt nach diesem wahltag auf begeht die
fraktion in diese nächste phase rein
dafür hat den armin laschet ein
kompromissvorschlag gemacht in allen
mitgetragen haben deshalb hat man jetzt
für ein halbes jahr gewählt das ergebnis
war klar und damit war es ist ganz
eindeutige signal die fraktion ist
handlungsfähig und wir gehen das
gemeinsam in dieser woche aber was heißt
denn handlungsfähig also es hat ja schon
den eindruck als wäre die union jetzt
wieder einmal
hauptsächlich mit sich selbst
beschäftigt ähnlich wie im wahlkampf
ganz im gegenteil deshalb war es richtig
dass man gestern diese frage geklärt hat
dass wir dieses wohl schon gemacht haben
und jetzt beschäftigen wir uns mit den
inhalt mit dem was jetzt ansteht aber
auch mit dem was in der union ansteht
und das steht ein erneuerungsprozess an
natürlich müssen wir es auch im lichte
des sonntags aber im lichte der ganzen
letzten monate und jahre
vorangehen es ist viel gutes erreicht
werden aber in 16 jahren regierung da
schleicht sich auch was ein und wir
müssen jetzt einen erneuerungsprozess
vorantreiben wir haben begonnen gehabt
den prozess für ein neues
grundsatzprogramm der ist ein auf eis
gelegt wurden wegen krone weil die
bundestagswahl kam da müssen wir jetzt
ran wir müssen klar machen wofür stehen
wir als union dann wird es ein junge
wähler zu erreichen dann muss es ist
auch wieder gelingen die wähler in den
großen städten besser zu erreichen da
steht es an daran arbeiten wir herr jung
sie sprechen von erneuerungen aber geht
das ganz ohne personelle erneuerung also
die kritik an armin laschet in der
fraktion scheint ja doch sehr groß zu
sein einige verlangten gestern von ihm
verantwortung zu übernehmen was ja einer
rücktrittsforderung gleichkommen was
erwarten sie denn in dieser schwierigen
situation von ihnen
das war gestern eine offene aussprache
da gab es die kritische stimmen die sie
genannt haben es gab vor allem
eine breite meinung das ist jetzt nicht
um personalfragen geht sind das jetzt
schon geht das wir uns aufstellen für
die nächsten für die nächste zeit dass
wir uns um die inhalte kümmern wollen
dass wir uns gesprächen nicht verweigern
sondern dass wir dafür offen sind und
dass wenn wir gespräche führen dass wir
die natürlich konstruktiv führen mit dem
geist etwas gutes für unser land zu
erreichen csu chef markus söder hat ja
gestern auf seine ganz eigene art und
weise amen lasset kritisiert man müsse
ein wahlergebnis respektieren betonte
söder etwa dazu gehöre auch olaf scholz
zu gratulieren was armin laschet ja
bisher nicht getan hat dabei gehe es um
eine stilfrage wie hilfreich ist denn so
etwas jetzt wenn die union doch sehr
bemüht ist gerade geschlossenheit und
handlungsfähigkeit zu demonstrieren
diese geschlossenheit die habe ich
gestern in der fraktion sehr
wahrgenommen
ich habe auch keine differenzen ich hab
da auch keine differenzen erlebt das ist
doch klar die spd ist auf dem ersten
platz wir sind auf dem zweiten platz
dann kommen die grünen und die fdp
deshalb alle so anerkannt und das ein
ergebnis mit dem man ist um zu gehen
halt das selbstverständlich respektiert
wird und auf dieser grundlage haben wir
jetzt unsere schlüsse gezogen
für die fragen die anstehen aber was
sagen sie denn zu der deutlichen kritik
von markus söder die können wir nicht
einfach wegwischen
es geht gar nicht um wegwischen wir
haben gestern alles auf den tisch gelegt
das war in der fraktion kein
scherbengericht so eine offene
aussprache
da stand nicht personen im mittelpunkt
stand die frage wie stellen wir uns auf
für die nächste zeit aber auch was sehen
wir verschlüsse darüber hinaus jetzt da
ging es gar nicht in der fraktion in
erster linie um regierung oder
opposition sind da ging es darum wie
können wir als union uns so aufstellen
dass wir ein konzept haben mit dem wir
alle erreichen mit dem er für alle
angebote machen aus meiner sicht ist
dass das konzept der nachhaltigkeit
ökologische und soziale marktwirtschaft
da müssen wir verstehen stand man in
unserem grundsatzprogramm muss wieder
rein das muss konkret werden wir müssen
es glaubwürdig vertreten und dann werden
wir einen zukunftsentwurf haben mit dem
wir überzeugen können dass stand gestern
im mittelpunkt der konstanzer südkurier
schreibt über sie andreas jung ist so
grün wie winfried kretschmann schwarz
ist welche chancen sehen sie also in
einem jamaika bündnis für deutschland
und inwieweit können sie da wenn es
wirklich dazu kommen sollte zu
gesprächen als schwarz grüner
brückenbauer die
winfried kretschmann hat gestern wir
auch den koalitionsvertrag in baden
württemberg als blaupause bezeichnet ich
will eben so unterstreichen was da
verhandelt wurde der sind wir zwei
partner mit unterschiedlichen akzenten
zusammengekommen das kann beispielgebend
sein ist ein starkes programm für
klimaschutz für erneuerbare energien für
neue technologien für nachhaltigkeit und
jamaika bei der frage nach jamaika wird
die fdp ihre akzente einbringen aber es
ein beispiel dafür wie unterschiedliche
partner zusammen sein zusammenkommen
können ich durfte der in baden
württemberg mit verhandeln ich bin
bereit wenn es gefragt ist mein
inhaltlichen beitrag hier weiter zu
leisten wir müssen beim klimaschutz ganz
unabhängig jetzt von koalitionsfragen
wir müssen beim klimaschutz ein weg
konsequent gehen der müssen wir
glaubwürdig gehen dadurch war kein
zweifel lassen das ist unser anliegen
nicht aus strategischen gründen um
partner zu gewinnen sonst unser anliegen
als union wegen unserer werte bindung
wegen unserem anspruch politik für die
zukunft zu machen da gibt es kein vertun
sagt andreas jung ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch
herzlichen dank